- 「量子情報と計算の理解」へ
ようこそ。
私はJohn Watrous、
IBM Quantum EducationのTechnical Directorだ。
これはシリーズの第4回目のレッスンで、
量子情報の基礎を扱う
シリーズ第1ユニットの最終レッスンだ。
ここまで、単一および複数のシステムにおける
量子情報の仕組みについて話してきた。
また、quantum circuit modelについても見てきた。
そして、量子情報に関する
いくつかの根本的な制限についても確認した。
その過程で、テンソル積や内積など
重要な数学的概念に出会った。
これらの概念は引き続き使っていくし、
必要に応じて新しい概念も
導入していく。
このレッスンでは、三つの基本的かつ重要な例、
quantum teleportation、superdense coding、
そしてCHSHゲームに焦点を当てる。
CHSHゲームはCHSH不等式とも呼ばれ、
必ずしもゲームとして説明されるわけじゃない。
これらは量子情報の仕組みを示すための
単なるランダムな例じゃなく、
本当に量子情報の基礎を成す
重要な部分であり、
量子情報と計算の中で
異なる、時には予想外の場面で登場する。
この三つの例すべてにおいて
エンタングルメントが重要な役割を果たしており、
実際にそれらを機能させているのは
エンタングルメントだ。
そしてエンタングルメントが面白さの源でもある。
だからこのレッスンは、ある意味で、
エンタングルメントが実際に動いている様子を
目にする最初の機会となり、
エンタングルメントを面白くしているものが
何なのかを探っていく機会になる。
レッスンの概要はとてもシンプルで、
先ほど挙げた三つの例を一つずつ順番に見ていく。
quantum teleportation、
superdense coding、そしてCHSHゲームだ。
これらが何であるか、そして何が面白いのかを議論し、
数学的なレベルで正確にどう機能するかを
説明する分析を行っていく。
三つの例のうち最初のquantum teleportationに
入る前に、まず登場人物を
紹介するのが適切だろう。
AliceとBob、もし知らなければの話だが。
AliceとBobは、システムやプロトコル、ゲームにおける
仮想的な存在やエージェントに付けられた名前だ。
そして実際、情報のやり取りを含む
あらゆる種類のインタラクションに使われる。
これらは1970年代に暗号学の文脈で
初めて登場したが、
こうした使い方でこれらの名前を使う慣習は
非常に一般的になった。
それ以降、より広い文脈で使われるようになった。
考え方としては、これらは少なくとも
世界のいくつかの地域ではよくある名前であり、
AとBという文字で始まる。
また、簡潔さのために
AliceとBobをそれぞれherとhimという代名詞で
呼ぶのも便利だ。
AliceとBobは通常、異なる場所にいると想定され、
異なる目標と異なる行動を持つとされる。
それは私たちが話している内容によって変わる。
例えば、情報の伝送を意味する
通信について話している場合、
Aliceが送信者だと決めることがある。
そして、Bobが伝送される
情報の受信者になる。
AliceとBobが協力することも多い、
これは非常に典型的だ。
でも時には競争したり、
一致するかどうかわからない
異なる目標を持つこともある。
それは状況によって
明確にされなければならない。
もちろん、彼らは抽象的な存在を表しており、
必ずしも実際の人間ではない。
CharlieやDianeなどの追加の登場人物を
導入することもできる。
または、Eveのような
異なるペルソナを表す別の名前も使える。
Eveは盗聴者、Malloryは
悪意を持って行動する人物を表す、
これは状況によって異なる。
いずれにしても、このレッスンで議論する
三つの例すべてにAliceとBobが登場し、
時折
シリーズの残りの部分でも登場する。
三つの例に移る前に、
エンタングルメントについて
いくつかコメントしておく。
レッスン2で、2つのqubitがエンタングルした状態の
例に出会った。
これは四つのbell stateのうちの一つで、
この特定の状態がエンタングルした量子状態の
典型的な例だと言える。
エンタングルした量子状態の典型例だ。
また、2ビットの確率的状態の
例にも出会った。
ある意味でエンタングルした状態と
類似しているが、エンタングルしていない。
エンタングルメントは唯一の
量子現象であり、
本質的に定義によるものだ。
エンタングルメントとは何かについての
正確な数学的定義があり、
基本的にその定義が示すのはエンタングルメントが
非古典的な量子相関だということだ。
しかし、それは直感的なレベルでは
それほど役に立たない。
エンタングルメントを、エンタングルメントでないものの
観点から定義しているからだ。
おそらくそのような理由から、
直感的な言葉でエンタングルメントとは何か、
そして何が特別なのかを説明するのは
かなり難しい。
直感的な言葉でエンタングルメントを
説明しようとする人たちは、
この二つの状態を実際には
区別しない説明をよく耳にする。
意味のある方法で区別できないんだ。
2つのエンタングルしたqubitのうちの一つを測定すると、
もう一方の状態が
何らかの形で瞬時に影響を受けるとか、2つのqubitの状態を別々に記述できないとか
あるいは2つのqubitが
何らかの形でお互いの記憶を保持しているとか、
さらには感情的に結びついているとか。
でも、なぜそういった性質が
この状態には当てはまらないのか？
この2つのビットは密接に結びついていて、それぞれが文字通りの意味でもう一方を完璧に記憶している、でも
これはエンタングルした状態じゃない。
エンタングルメントを特別にするものと、この状態が
あの状態とまったく違う理由を説明する一つの方法は、エンタングルメントで
何ができるかを説明することだ
あるいは、エンタングルメントによって起こることを観察することで、
知識をベクトルで表現する際の選択を超えたところにある何かを見ることができる。
このレッスンで取り上げる3つの例は
どれもこういった性質を持っていて、エンタングルメントでできることのうち
この状態では
あるいは古典的に相関した状態ではできないことを示している。
実際、量子情報と量子計算の研究では、エンタングルメントをリソースとして捉えるのが一般的だ
そのリソースを通じて、さまざまな
タスクを達成できる。
そうして考えるとき、この状態は
エンタングルメントの1単位を表していると見なせる。
このエンタングルメントの単位を
e-bitと呼ぶ。eはentangledまたはentanglementの頭文字だ。
確かに2つのqubitだが、エンタングルメントの量として見れば1 e-bitだ。
また、以前出てきた相関した確率的な状態にある
普通の古典ビットのペアも、
1ビットの共有乱数というリソースと見なすことができる。
暗号において、誰にも知られていないという前提で
ランダムなビットを誰かと共有することは非常に有用で、それを
秘密鍵として使えるからだ
あるいは、暗号化のために、例えば秘密鍵の一部として使える。
でもこのレッスンでは、このエンタングルした状態と
それで何ができるかに焦点を当てる。
用語を明確にしておくと、AliceとBobが1 e-bitを共有するというのは、
AliceがAという名前のqubitを持っているという意味だ
BobはBという名前のqubitを持っていて、ペアA, Bは合わせて
Phi plus状態にある。
もちろん2つのqubitにどんな名前をつけるかは重要じゃない、
別の名前を選んでもいい、でもこのレッスン全体を通じて
わかりやすさのためにこれらの名前を使い続ける
明確さを期するためだ。レッスンの最初の例は
quantum teleportationだ、
簡潔さのために、以降は
単にteleportationと呼ぶことにする。
teleportationとは、送信者がエンタングルメントだけを使って
量子情報を受信者に伝送できるプロトコルで
その伝送を成し遂げるために
古典通信を使う。
これはSFにおけるteleportationという言葉の典型的な解釈、
つまり物質がある場所から消えて
別の場所に現れるというものとは、まったく無関係だ。
quantum teleportationは、いわばそのイメージやメタファーを呼び起こすための名前に過ぎない。
teleportされるのは物質じゃなく
量子情報であり、それは古典情報の伝送と
エンタングルメントを通じて実現される。
teleportationがどう機能するかを正確に理解するには、
いわば舞台を設定するところから始めるのが助けになる。
AliceとBobが登場するシナリオを想像してみよう、
そのシナリオは次の通りだ、
AliceはQという名前のqubitを持っていて、
それをBobに伝送したい、つまり
プロトコルを開始するとき、Qと全く同じ状態にある
qubitをBobが手に持っていてほしいということだ。
言い換えれば、情報伝送、つまり通信という
基本的な問題を扱っているわけだ。
Aliceという送信者と
Bobという受信者がいて、AliceはqubitとしてBobに
量子情報を送りたい。
ただし制約がある。AliceはQをBobに物理的に送ることができず、できるのはBobに古典情報を送ることだけだ。
AliceとBobにはさらに
追加のリソースがある。それはe-bitを共有していることだ。
これがシナリオだ、Aliceが
物理的にQを送れないという制約が
合理的な抽象化となる状況は容易に想像できる。
例えば、AliceとBobが
異なる大陸にいる場合、あるいはAliceがBobの正確な居場所を知らない場合、物理的にqubitを送るのは
おそらくかなり難しいだろう。
でも古典通信なら
もちろんそういった状況でも可能なだけでなく、かなり安上がりだ。
さて、AliceとBobが共有e-bitなしにこのタスクを達成できるかどうか疑問に思うかもしれない。
言い換えれば、古典通信だけで
qubitを伝送する方法はあるのか？
答えはノーで、古典通信だけで量子情報を伝送することはできない、これはそれほど証明が難しいわけじゃない
基本的な量子情報理論を使えばわかることで、シリーズの
第3ユニットで見ることになる。
今のところ、直感的に考えるには
no-cloning定理について考えるといい。
古典的な通信だけを使って
量子情報を送る方法があったとしよう。
でも、古典的な通信は
簡単にコピーしてブロードキャストできる。つまり、
その古典的な通信は
2人の受信者、例えばBobとCharlieに
ブロードキャストできてしまう。
もし2人ともAliceから
同じ古典的な情報を受け取ったとしたら、
2人ともQを手に入れることになるのか？
それはQをクローンしたことになるが、それは不可能だとわかってる。
少し余談になるが、
古典的な情報を使って
量子状態ベクトルを記述することは確かに可能だ。
このシリーズで見る量子状態ベクトルは
すべて、君が見てるデバイスに
送信された古典的な情報を使って
説明されてる。
一般的に、Qがどんな状態にあるかを
classical bitsを使って
ある精度で記述することを考えられる。
でもそれは量子通信じゃなくて、
量子状態をベクトルとして記述してるだけだ。
その違いについては
もう少ししたら戻ってくる。
ただ、このシナリオに戻って、
AliceとBobがe-bitを共有してるという
前提で考えると、AliceとBobが
タスクを達成するために
必要なものをすべて持ってることがわかる。
それが量子テレポーテーションprotocolの役割で、
具体的には2bitsの古典的な通信を使う。
詳細に入る前に、
前提条件が明確になるよう、
いくつか簡単に述べておく。
まず、ここではQの状態は
AliceとBobにとって未知だと仮定してる。
特に、
AliceはBobにQの状態の説明を
送ることができない。
一般的には彼女がそれを知らないからだ。
また、Qが他のシステムと
相関してる可能性も考慮しなければならない。
エンタングルしてる可能性も含めて。
他のシステムとのエンタングルメントがある場合、
このqubitをBobに送る際には
その相関を保存しなければならない。
最後に、qubitを古典的に通信しようとした話の中で
no-cloning定理に触れたが、
ここにも別の関連がある。
no-cloning定理との関連というのは、
BobがAliceからこのqubit Qの送信を受け取ったなら、
Aliceはもうそれを持っていてはいけないということだ。
Qはクローンできないから。これはテレポーテーションprotocolを考える際に
頭に入れておくべきことだ。
テレポーテーションprotocolは、
ここで見るようにquantum circuit図を使って
かなりシンプルかつ直接的に記述できる。
AliceのパートとBobのパートの分離を
描いているという点で
少し様式化されてるが、
それ以外はただのquantum circuit図だ。
点線より上がすべてAliceの操作で、
下がすべてBobの操作を表してる。
時間は常に左から右に進む。
そして、この2つのqubitがPhi plus状態から
始まるのが見える。
これがe-bit、つまり
AliceとBobが最初に持ってるものだ。
qubitにラベルを付けて
どれがどれかわかるようにしよう。
これがqubit A、これがe-bitを形成する
qubit Bだ。
そして、これがAliceが
Bobに送りたいqubit Qだ。
ここでは、このqubit Qの状態がPsiだと
仮定してるが、
少し後でQがエンタングルしてる可能性も
考えてみる。
他のシステムと。そして図が主張してるのは、
ここにpsiを書いたということは、
このcircuitが
AliceのパートにあったPsiの状態を
Bobのパートに実質的に送信するということだ。
唯一の通信は、
AliceとBobの間の線を越える
2つのclassical bitsで、
ここの二重線で表されてる。
このdiagramを少し小さくして
もう少し余裕を作り、
circuitをもっと詳しく見てみよう。
初期条件はすでに説明したが、
改めて言うと、Aliceはqubit Aを持ち、
Bobはqubit Bを持ってる。
AとBは合わせて
Phi plus状態にある。
それがe-bitを共有するということだ。
AliceにはBobに送りたいqubit Qもある。
Qが任意の量子状態Psiにある場合を考えてる。
今、AliceとBobがどうやって
このe-bitを手に入れたかは
わからない。
もう長い間持ってたのかもしれない。
以前同じ場所にいたときに
作ったのかもしれない。
この機会のために
保存しておいたのかもしれないが、
その詳細はここでは関係ない。
次に起こるステップ、つまり
テレポーテーションprotocol自体を表すものは
以下の通りだ。明確にするために、
これらはdiagramが描いてるステップで、
diagramが何を表してるか
わかりやすいよう、言葉で書き下してるだけだ。
Aliceはまずcontrolled-NOT操作を行う。
Bobに送りたいqubit Qがcontrolで、
qubit Aがtargetだ。
次のステップはQにHadamard操作を行い、
それから彼女が持つ2つのqubitを測定する。
AとQを標準基底測定で測定し、
lowercase aをqubit Aの測定結果とする。
小文字のbをqubit Qの測定結果とする。
Aliceはその2つの古典ビットをBobに送る。これがこのプロトコルで唯一の通信であり、図中でもそれが示されている。
この2つのビットがAliceとBobの間の点線を越えているのがその証拠で、その点線は2人の間の距離を表していると考えればいい。
Bobがビットaとbをもらったあとにやることは2つだ。
まず、aが1に等しければ、X演算、つまりNOT gateを自分のqubit Bに対して行う。
aが0なら、何もしない。
同様に、bが1に等しければ、BobはZ演算、つまりZ-gate、あるいは位相反転を行う。
やはりqubit bに対して。bが0なら、何もしない。
これは図の中で、制御ビットが2つの古典ビットであるcontrolled-Xとcontrolled-Z gateとして示されている。
これらのgateをcontrol gateとして考える必要はない。これはやりたいことを表すための便利な方法にすぎない。
circuit図の形で表すためだ。要点は、aが1ならBobはqubit bにX-gateを適用し、次にZ-gateを
Bが1ならqubit bに適用するということだ。
あとで便利なように、BobがqubitBに対して行う複合演算を、Aliceが送る古典ビットに応じて
明示的に書き下すことができる。
これがテレポーテーションプロトコルだ。かなりシンプルだが、実際に機能するかどうかは別の話で、解析はそれほど
複雑ではないとはいえ、なぜ機能するのかがすぐにわからなくても、何かを見落としているとは思わなくていい。
だから解析を進める必要があって、次にそれをやる。
テレポーテーションプロトコルを解析するために、3つのqubitの状態が時間の各時点でどうなっているかを一歩ずつ確認していく。
まず、上のqubitがAlphaZero足すbeta one という状態にある場合を考える。alphaとbetaは任意の複素数で、
このベクトルが単位ベクトルになるような値だ。
これがAliceが送ろうとしているqubit Qだが、今この瞬間はその名前はあまり気にしなくていい。
少し後で、このqubitが別のシステムとエンタングルしているケースも見るが、シンプルに保つためには
今はこれが良い出発点で、解析の仕組みも少し明確に見えてくる。
ここでスタート時点の3つのqubitの状態を一緒に考えると、その状態がここに見える形をしているとわかる。
最初の2つのqubitはPhi plus状態にあり、3つ目のqubitが上のものだ。これはqubitの順序に関する規則による。
前のレッスンで説明したが、テンソル積を取ることで3つのqubitの状態をまとめて表す。
この式は、まずPhi plus状態の定義を代入し、次にテンソル積を計算することで展開できる。
そうするとここに見えている状態が得られる。
ちなみに、こういったベクトルを完全に展開するのが常に最善の戦略とは限らない。一般的には、
展開する理由が明確になるまで待つのが賢明だ。
ただここでは理由がある。このcontrolled NOT gateの作用を計算したいからで、状態をこの形で書くことで、
それが非常に簡単にできる。
特にこれが、controlled NOT gateを適用した後の3つのqubitの状態だ。
3つ目のqubitがcontrol qubitで、規則上それが上にあるものだ。そして2つ目のqubit、つまり真ん中のものが
targetだ。だからketに対応した操作をするだけで、3番目のビットが0なら何も起きない。
3番目のビットが1なら、2番目のビットを反転する。
次に3番目のqubitにHadamard gateを適用して、得られるベクトルを以下のように書ける。
zeroとone状態をplus状態とminus状態に置き換えて表している。
これを展開するために十分なスペースを確保するには少し縮小する必要がある。そして今、plus状態とminus状態を
その定義で置き換えて、分母に2の平方根を持ってくると、ここで見える状態が得られる。
そしてそれを展開すると、ここで見える状態が得られる。
これがAliceが2つの操作を行った後の3つのqubitの状態だ。
次にAliceが測定を行う。測定を解析したい場合は、レッスン2で話したように、測定されるシステムの標準基底ベクトルを取り出す。
この特定のケースでそれをやると、こういう結果が得られる。
この式をしばらく見ると、少し不思議に思えるかもしれない。今や最初のqubit、つまり
下のqubitが何らかの形でalphaとbetaに依存しているように見えるが、この時点では点線を越えた通信はまだ行われていないのに。
でもそれは錯覚に過ぎない。スカラーのfloatはtensor productを
自由に通過することを覚えておこう。だからalphaとbetaが
最初のqubitに関連付けられているという意味は、実際にはない。
ここで実際にやったことは、
tensor productの多重線形性に従って
括弧を使っただけだ。
いずれにせよ、測定が何をするかを確認するために必要な形式はこれで、
すぐにひとつ興味深いことが見えてくる。
それは、4つの測定結果の確率が常に一様だということだ。
各測定結果のペアを測定する確率は4分の1だ。特に、
alphaとbetaには
一切依存しない。
それぞれのケースで、孤立させた標準基底ベクトルに
tensor積されたベクトルのユークリッドノルムの2乗を計算することで確認できる。
どのケースでも4分の1が得られる。これは2分の1の2乗に
alphaの絶対値の2乗をかけたものだ。
それにbetaの絶対値の2乗を足すと1になる。
だからどのケースでも4分の1になる。
実際、これらの異なる結果の確率が
Aliceが送信したいqubitに
一切依存しないことは、非常に重要だ。
任意の状態がここに入ってきてここから出ていく、
しかも測定がその状態について
情報を明かすということはあり得ない。
任意の量子状態について情報を得たいなら、
一般にその状態を乱さなければならない。
これは、異なる結果の確率だけでなく、
3つのqubitすべての状態も示したテーブルだ。
各測定結果を条件とした場合の状態だ。
異なる標準基底状態にtensor積されたベクトルを正規化することで得られるが、
このケースでは簡単だ。
単位ベクトルを得るために2分の1の因子を取り除くだけだ。
つまり、Aliceが測定した直後の状態は、
Aliceが2つの一様乱数ビットを持っている、それだけだ。
特に、彼女はもはや元の状態を持っておらず、
それについての情報も持っていない。
ただランダムなビットがあるだけだ。
Bobの状態は今や
alphaとbetaにも、測定結果にも依存する。
Aliceがまだ測定結果を送っていない状況を
一時的に想像してみよう。
つまりBobは測定結果を知らない。
その場合、彼は自分のqubitを測定しても
alphaとbetaについて
何の情報も得られない。
ここにある4つの可能性は、
alphaとbetaについての情報が
一切得られないよう十分にかき混ぜられている。
どんな測定でも情報を得ることはできない。
これは直感的なレベルで真でなければならない、
さもなければ光速より速い通信が可能になってしまうからだ。
Aliceは何も送らずにBobに情報を
伝えることはできない。もちろんAliceは測定結果を
送ることになる。
Bobに送るわけだから、Bobが操作を行うと
何が起こるかを見るためにテーブルを拡張しよう。
この列には、測定結果の各パターンに対して
Bobが実質的に行う異なる操作が示されている。
先ほど観察したように、1つずつ見ていって
その操作をBobのqubit（最初のB）に
適用すると、
4つのケースすべてで同じ結果が得られる。
その結果は元の状態だ。
つまり、qubit Qの元の状態が
Bへのテレポートに成功した。
Bobがこの時点で自分のqubitをQと名付けたければ
もちろん構わない。しかし重要なのは、今や
彼が元の状態を持っているということだ。
Aliceが持っていた状態だ。そしてもちろん必然的に、
Aliceはもうそれを持っていない。
e-bitもこのプロセスを通じて
実質的に消費されることにも注意しよう。
テレポーテーションにはコストがある。
そのコストは1つのe-bitと2ビットの古典的通信だ。
プロトコルが終わると、e-bitは消えている。
これで、一番上のqubitがある量子状態にある
という仮定のもとで
テレポーテーションプロトコルが正しく動作することを確立した。
alphaかけるket 0プラスbetaかけるket 1
という形の状態だ。
しかし、一番上のqubitが
追加のqubitなど他のシステムと
エンタングルしていたらどうなるか。
画面に表示されているようなケースだ。
そのような状況でテレポーテーションを
使いたい場合もあるかもしれない。
AliceとBobが実際に100回のテレポーテーションを
計画しているかもしれない。Aliceが
100 qubitの量子レジスタを
1 qubitずつBobに送信するためだ。
あるいは、追加のqubitはそもそも
Aliceの手元になく、他の誰かが持っているかもしれない。
Aliceはそれらの存在すら知らないかもしれない。
問題は、テレポートされるqubitが
別のシステムとエンタングルしていても
テレポーテーションは機能するのかということだ。
ここでは、qubit Qと考慮している追加システムの状態が
上に表示されているように表現されている。
gamma zeroとgamma oneは、
この追加システムの量子状態を表す
単位ベクトルだ。
複合システムの任意の状態は常にこのように書ける。
実際にはalphaとbetaは必要ないが、
それらを含めれば、gamma zeroとgamma oneを
単位ベクトルとして取れる。
そうすることで、既に検討した
より単純なケースとのつながりが
より明確になる。
既にやったのと同様の分析を
進めることができるが、この追加のシステムも
追跡しながら進める。
追加のシステムがあるので少し複雑になるが、
考え方はまったく同じだ。ここに簡単なまとめを示す。
これが初期状態で、controlled NOT gate後の
状態がこれだ。
そして、Hadamard演算後の
これらを展開すると、ここに見えるように
その状態を表現できる。
これがAliceの測定直前の状態で、
前と同様に可能性を見ていくと、
Bobが適用すべき演算を
適用した場合に何が起きるかを考えると、
確かに正しい状態が得られ、
プロトコルは期待通りに動作することがわかる。
ちなみにこの表では、この追加のシステムを
表すのに文字Rを使っていて、
かなりシンプルなトリックを使っているのがわかる。
少なくとも一時的には、システムの順序を
B、R、A、Qにしたほうがいいということだ。
そのほうがここで状態を書くのに
便利だからだ。
図によれば、システムの順序は
B、A、Q、Rであるべきだが、
明確にさえすれば、より便利な
別の順序を選んでも構わない。
要するに、この分析で起きていることは
すべてシンプルな分析と同じで、
ただ、これらの追加ベクトル、gamma zeroとgamma oneが
いわば「ついてくる」形になっているだけだ。
alphaの因子があるときは常にgamma zeroがあり、
betaの因子があるときはgamma oneがある。
最終的にはすべて正しく収まる。
これは実はまったく驚くことではない。
qubitに対してidentity演算のように働く
物理的なプロセスがあって、
任意の量子状態に対してそうなるとき、
それが起こりうる唯一の方法は
その演算がidentity演算であることだ。
これは量子情報の一般的な定式化を使えば
少し説明しやすいが、要点は線形性によって、
この追加の分析をわざわざ行う必要は
実はなかったということだ。
単独の qubitに対してテレポーテーションが
正しく動作することがわかれば、
起こりうることは一つしかないと結論づけられる。
プロトコルが何をするかを記述するのは、
ここでqubitが入ってきてidentity演算を
実装するということだけだ。
そしてqubitはここから出てきて、事実上
完全なノイズなし量子チャネルとして機能する。
テレポーテーションについていくつか
簡単な補足をしてから、このレッスンの
2番目の例であるsuperdense codingに移ろう。
まず、テレポーテーションは量子情報の
応用ではなくプロトコルだということを
明確にしておくのが重要だと思う。
具体的には量子通信を
行うためのプロトコルだ。
私が説明したようなテレポーテーションが
役立つためには、量子通信を行う理由が
何かなければならない。
次に、テレポーテーションはいつか量子情報を
伝達する標準的な方法になり得ると
推測するのは合理的だ。
具体的には、entanglement distillationとして
知られるプロセスが
潜在的に使われる可能性がある。
qubitを確実に通信する方法として。
AliceとBobが量子情報を通信する予定があるか、
量子情報を通信する必要がある場合、
このentanglement distillationのプロセスを使って、
より多くのノイジーなe-bitを
より少ない高品質なe-bitに変換し、
それをノイズなしまたはノイズの少ない
テレポーテーションに使うことができる。
考え方は、entanglement distillationのプロセスは
ある意味でそれほど繊細ではないということだ。
損失を受け入れて、うまくいかなければ、
もう一度試せばいい。一方、実際に通信したい
qubitはずっと貴重なものと考えられるかもしれない。
もちろんこれはすべて推測だが、要点は
テレポーテーションが非常に実用的な方法になる
状況を仮定するのは難しくないということだ。
qubitを通信する
非常に実用的な方法として。
テレポーテーションに関する最後の点として、
テレポーテーションの背景にある考え方と
その仕組みはかなり根本的なものだ。
量子情報と計算において、テレポーテーションは
量子情報理論の本当に基礎的なものであり、
バリエーションも
よく出てくる。一例を挙げると、
テレポーテーションを使って異なるquantum gateを
実装する提案がある。
ただし異なる初期状態と測定を選択することで、
結果として
通信ではなく選択した演算を
適用することになる。
次の例はsuperdense codingだ。
量子テレポーテーションと同様に、
superdense codingはプロトコルであり、
それが達成することはテレポーテーションと相補的だ。
テレポーテーションはe-bitと2ビットの
古典通信を使って1つのqubitを
送信できるのに対して、
superdense codingは
e-bitと1つのqubitの量子通信を使って
2つの古典ビットを送信できる。
つまり簡単に言えば、superdense codingは
古典情報の送信を可能にし、
superdense codingと呼ばれる理由は
2つの古典ビットの通信を
単一のqubitに詰め込めるということだ、
ただし、これを実現するには
e-bitを消費しなければならない。
ここで、セットアップについて
より正確な説明をしよう。
再び、AliceとBobが登場する。AliceはSenderで
BobはReceiverだ。今回、Aliceは2つの古典ビットを持っていて、
それをBobに送りたいと思っている。
Aliceは単一のqubitをBobに送ることができ、AliceとBobは
タスクを達成するために使えるe-bitを共有している。
そのタスクとは、Bobが
2つの古典ビットを受け取ることだ。
さて、あるいみでこのタスクは
テレポーテーションが達成するタスクより
面白みに欠けるように見えるかもしれない。
特に、qubitを送ることは古典ビットを送ることより
大幅に難しかったり困難だったりすると
考えるなら、
それはかなり合理的な見方だが、これが可能だということは間違いなく興味深い。
興味深い理由の一つは、
e-bitを使わずに単一のqubitだけで
2つの古典ビットの情報を伝送する
というこのタスクを達成することは
実際に不可能だということだ。
これはHolevoの定理として知られる
有名な定理によってわかっている。
Holevoの定理はこれより
一般的で、正確な記述は
やや技術的であり、
いくらかの説明が必要だが、
その含意の一つは、量子通信のqubitより少ない数で
古典ビットを伝送することはできないということだ。
qubitを使って2つの古典ビットの情報を
確実に伝送したいのに
使えるe-bitがないなら、
2つのqubitを送ることになる。だから、伝送したいビットをそのまま格納すればいい。
スーパーデンス符号化が興味深いもう一つの理由は、
テレポーテーションとの密接な
相補的関係にあり、
これについては後で戻ってくる。
少し後で。これがスーパーデンス符号化プロトコルのquantum circuit記述だ。
今回はすべてのステップを列挙せず、
circuit図の記述だけで済ませよう。
見てわかるように、再び
AliceとBobがいる。Aliceが上で
Bobが下だ。
これがAliceとBobの間で
最初に共有されるe-bitで、
プロトコルが実行される前に
何らかの方法で確立されている。
AliceはAとBという2つの古典ビットを持ち、
ここで確認できる。circuit が記述するプロトコルを通じて、
この2つの古典ビットは
Bobの手に渡ることになる。
AliceとBobの境界を越える
qubitはたった一つで、もちろん
古典ビットは送られない。
2つの古典ビットの伝送こそが
このプロトコルの目的だ。
テレポーテーションで使われるものと
まったく同じ要素が使われていることにも気づくだろう。
controlled NOT gate、Hadamard gate、
そして古典ビットで制御される
Z gateとX gateだ。
ただし配置は異なる。では分析に進んで
どう機能するか見ていこう。
スーパーデンス符号化の仕組みを分析するために、
分析の核心にあるBell基底を
書き下すところから始めよう。
まず、AliceのアクションがPhi plusの状態に
与える影響を見ていく。
わかるのは、Aliceがこの
Phi plusの状態を、
送りたいビットに応じて
4つのBell状態の一つに変換するということだ。
では、何が起きているか追跡できるように
テーブルを書き下そう。
まず、AとBがともにゼロの場合、Z gateもX gateも適用されないので、
Aliceのアクションは何もしない。
つまり、Phi plusは
Phi plusにマップされる。
これはここで見るような等式としても表せる。
Aliceのqubitには何も起こらず、
Bobのqubitにも何も起こらない。
何もしないことは
単位行列で表される。
では、AがゼロでかつBが1の場合はどうなるか？
Bが1なので、Z gateを適用し、
AがゼロなのでX gateは適用しない。
全体的な効果として、AliceがZ gateを実行することがわかる。
Aliceは上にいるので右にある。
この特定のケースでは実際には
何の違いもないが、効果は
Phi plusの状態が
Phi minusにスナップされることだ。
Z gateの動作を覚えていれば、
この式から見て取れる。
テーブルにこれを追加できる。あと2つのケースが残っている。Aが1で
Bがゼロの場合、
AliceはX gateを実行し、
Phi plusをChi plusに変換する。AとBがともに1の場合、
AliceはZ、次にX を実行し、
Chi minusが得られる。
テーブルは4つのケースそれぞれで何が起こるかを示していて、
AliceはどのBell状態を選ぶかを実質的に選択することになる。
4つのBell状態のうちどれをBobと共有したいかを選べて、自分のqubitだけに作用することで自由に選択できる
それがエンタングルメントの
かなり面白い側面だ。
AliceはそのqubitをBobに送る。
この時点で、BobはBell状態の4つのうちの1つを持っていて、どれかを
判断するだけでいい
ビットを復元するためにな。
そして確かに、
制御NOTゲートの後にHadamardゲートが続く構成が、図にある通り、正しい動作をすることを確認できる。
詳細には触れないが、やってみれば
ここの表に示された通りの結果になることがわかる。
確認する一つの方法は
単純に計算することだ。あるいは、これを実は逆順で
すでにやっていることに気づけばいい
前のレッスンでな。前のレッスンでは
Hadamardゲートが先で、制御NOTゲートが後だった
そしてそのcircuitが
標準基底状態をBell状態にマッピングし、1つのケースでは厄介な
マイナス符号が出ることを見た。
gateの順序を逆にして、
この2つのgateはどちらも自分自身の逆演算であるという事実を考慮すると、
得られるのは逆演算だ、
つまりこのケースでは
作用が逆方向に働く
マイナス符号はどちら側にあっても構わない、
それ以外は正しい場所にある。この時点で、
測定が正しい値を明かすのは
明らかだ、
ここのマイナス符号は問題ない。なぜならこのケースでは1つが
確率1で現れるからで、それが分析のすべてだ。
要するに、AliceがBell状態を選び、Bobがどれかを判断するということだ。
先に進む前に、superdense codingについて
簡単にいくつか言っておく。まず、superdense codingは
古典情報を送信する手段として
有用だったり実用的だったりする可能性は
おそらく低い。
古典的な通信は
非常に安価で、Qubitsを物理的に送ることは控えめに言っても難しい、
そういう状況が続く限り、superdense codingから
実用的なメリットは
全く期待できない。
でも実用的でない可能性が高いからといって、superdense
codingが面白くないということにはならない。
実際、とても面白い。まず、根底にあるアイデアは
本当に非常に根本的だ、
根底にあるアイデアというのは、AliceがBobとBell状態を
共有している場合、
その状態を彼女が選ぶ任意の他のBell状態に
自分一人で変更できるということだ。それをするのにBobの
助けは全く必要ない。
これはBell状態に関する具体的な例だが、もっと一般的な根底のアイデアがある。それは、あるプレイヤーが持つ自由度に関するものだ
別のプレイヤーと共有しているエンタングル状態を変換する自由度、そしてその自由度が正確に何かを理解することは
量子情報を理解する上での重要なステップで、シンプルにその自由度を正確にどう記述するかを見ていく
エレガントな形でな。シリーズの
第3ユニットでな。
Superdense codingはまた、
エンタングルメントで何ができるかの具体的な例を提供している。つまり、2つの古典的な
ビットを送信できるということだ
1つのqubitを送ることで。すでに述べたように、これはHolevoの定理により、エンタングルメントなしでは不可能であることが証明されている。
teleportationとsuperdense codingを合わせて考えると、それらが
同値性を確立しているのがわかる
量子通信の1 qubitと古典通信の2ビットの間のな。
1 e-bitを使う意思があれば、
効果的に
どちらか一方をもう一方に変換できる。
Teleportationは
2ビットの古典通信を使って1 qubitの通信を可能にし、superdense codingは逆方向に機能する
つまり1 qubitの量子通信を使って
2ビットの古典通信を可能にする。
しかし、e-bitを消費しないと、
どちらか一方をもう一方に変換することはできない。それを可能にするのが
エンタングルメントだ。
このレッスンで扱う3番目で最後の例は
プロトコルではなく、
CHSHゲームとして知られるゲームだ。
このコンテキストでゲームと言うとき、楽しみやスポーツのために
プレイするものを指しているわけではない、
むしろ、例えばゲーム理論という意味での数学的抽象化だ。
ゲームの数学的抽象化は、例えば経済学やコンピュータサイエンスで
非常によく研究されていて、
かなり多くの価値がある
抽象化の中に見出せる。だからゲームは全部楽しいというわけじゃない
ゲーム理論のゲームには、ということだが、
考えるのは楽しいけどな。
この特定のケースでは、本質的に
思考実験があって、それはゲームとして
かなり直感的な形で説明できる。
CHSHという文字は著者たちを指している。John Clauser、Michael
Horne、Abner Shimony、そしてRichard Holtによる1969年の
論文で、この例が
最初に説明された。彼らは実際にはゲームとして説明していない。この例を
CHSHゲームではなく、
むしろCHSH不等式と呼ぶのが一般的だ。
でも私のようなコンピュータサイエンティストにとっては、ゲームとして説明するのが
とても自然だ。
すでに示唆したように、
ゲームの数学的抽象化は重要でかつ有用で、多くの異なる
ゲームのカテゴリがある
考慮できるものだ。CHSHゲームは
非局所ゲームと呼ばれるゲームのクラスの一例だ。
非局所ゲームの一般的な
セットアップはこうだ。
チームとして協力するAliceとBobという二人のプレイヤーがいて、一緒に勝つか
一緒に負けるかのどちらかだ。
つまり、利己的に行動する
動機がないということだ。ゼロサムゲームとは本質的に
正反対の極にある。
ゼロサムゲームは純粋に競争的だが、このゲームは純粋に協調的だ。
審判と呼ばれる第三の存在がいる。
審判はゲームのプレイヤーではなく、むしろゲームを
進行させる役割を担っており、実際、その仕様について
非局所ゲームの特定のインスタンスの仕様と
審判の仕様は
等価だと考えることができる。
AliceとBobには極めて重要な制約が課されており、それはゲームが始まったら互いに
通信することが禁じられているということだ。
事前にどんな戦略でも
話し合うことはできるが、ゲーム中は
いかなる通信も許されない。
もし好むなら、何らかの
セキュアな施設でゲームが行われていると想像できる。まるで審判が
刑事の役割を果たし
AliceとBobが警察署の別々の
部屋にいる容疑者のようだ。しかし、このセットアップについて
別の考え方もある。
AliceとBobが
広大な距離で隔てられており、光の速度では間に合わないため通信が禁止されている
という状況だ。例えばAliceがBobにメッセージを
送ろうとしても、Bobがそれを受け取るころには
ゲームは終わっている。
非局所ゲームの
仕組みはこうだ。まず、審判がAliceとBob
両方に質問をする。
AliceへのQuestion はXと表記され、BobへのQuestionはYと表記される。
一般的に、XとYは好きな古典状態の集合からの
古典状態と考えることができ、CHSHゲームの
具体的なケースでは、
XとYはビットだ。
AliceとBobはその後答えを返さなければならない。AliceのAnswerはAと表記され、
BobのAnswerはBと表記される。
そして、これらのAnswerも一般的には古典状態として見ることができ、QuestionのようにCHSHゲームではビットになる。
この時点で、
審判が判断を下す。AliceとBobが勝つか負けるかは、AnswerのペアA、Bが
審判が尋ねたQuestionのペアX、Yに対して
正しいとみなされるかどうかによる。もう少し詳しく
説明しよう。
まず、非局所ゲームでAliceとBobにとって
潜在的に何が難しいのかを理解するために、
審判をより詳しく見てみよう。
非局所ゲームが潜在的に
難しい理由は、審判がランダム性を使ってQuestionのXとYを選べるからだ。
つまりAliceとBobは
不確実性を抱えており、どんなQuestionをされるか事前にわからない。そしておそらくより重要なことに、
相手がどんなQuestionを
受け取ったかもわからない。その不確実性と
通信できないという事実が合わさって
難しさを生み出している。
これは、刑事が二人の容疑者を
別々の部屋で尋問する状況と似ている。もし容疑者が
相手にどんなQuestionが聞かれているか知らなければ、彼らが有罪だった場合に口裏を合わせるのはずっと難しくなる。
少し前に述べたように、
審判はAliceとBobが
正しく答えたか間違って答えたかを判断する。
聞かれたQuestionに
よって決まる。
この判断は何らかの固定された
ルールに従って行われると仮定されており、どんなルールでも考えられるが、それが何であれ、
AliceとBobは
そのルールを知っていると仮定されている。少なくとも正しく答えるチャンスがあるわけだ。
CHSHゲームのルールは
すぐに見るが、別のルールを
考えれば、別の
非局所ゲームの例になる。
非局所ゲームの中には興味深いものがあり、実際、今日でもかなり魅力的で謎めいたものがある。
また、興味深くないものもある。
それが非局所ゲームモデルの
性質だ。
いずれにせよ、審判を説明するのに必要な二つのことがある。Questionがどのように選ばれるか
そして、各Questionのペアに対してどのAnswerのペアが正しいか。
この二つのことの説明があれば、
審判の説明があることになり、それが実質的に
非局所ゲームのインスタンスを記述している。
では、CHSHゲームを
具体的に見てみよう。
このゲームの定義、言い換えれば
審判の定義は以下の通りだ。
まず、すでに述べたように、QuestionとAnswerはすべてビットだ。審判はビットXを
AliceにビットYをBobに送る。
そして二人はそれぞれビットで答える。AliceはAで
BobはBで答える。
審判がどのQuestionを
聞くかを選ぶ方法はシンプルだ。一様にランダムに
選ぶ。
つまり、QuestionのペアX、Yは四つの可能性、ゼロゼロ、ゼロ一、
一ゼロ、一一の
どれかが等確率で選ばれる。
最後に、どのAnswerが勝ちでどのAnswerが負けかを
決めるルールだが、AnswerのペアA、BはQuestionのペアX、Yに対して正しい
AとBの排他的論理和がXとYの論理積に等しい場合、かつその場合に限る。
ここで見るようにそれらの条件を表の形で表すと
少し理解しやすくなるかもしれない。
最初の列には4つの質問ペアの可能性があり、2列目には
AとBに関する条件がある
AliceとBobが勝つために
必要な条件だ。
最初の3つのケースでは、
AとYの論理積はゼロなので、排他的論理和はゼロに等しくなければならない
彼らが勝つためには、
つまりAとBはビットなのでAとBは等しくなければならないということで、4番目のケースでは、
XとYの論理積は
1に等しいので、AliceとBobが勝つためにはAとBの排他的論理和は1に等しくなければならない
つまり
AとBは異なっていなければならないということだ。
これがCHSHゲームで、今度はAliceとBobのための
異なる戦略の可能性と、このゲームでどれだけうまくやれるかを考えることができる。
まず決定論的戦略について考えてみよう。AliceのAnswerのAは
彼女が受け取る質問Xの関数であり、
同様にBobのAnswer B
は彼が受け取る
質問Yの関数だ。
実のところ、いかなる
決定論的戦略も毎回勝つことはできない。
それを理由づける一つの方法は
単純にすべての可能な決定論的戦略を一つずつ調べて、その全てが負けることを確認することだ
4つの可能な質問ペアの
少なくとも1つで。
AliceとBobはそれぞれ
4つの可能な関数から選ぶことができ、その4つの関数はレッスン1で見たので、全体で確認すべき16の可能性がある。
もう一つの見方は
画面上の式について考えることで、決定論的戦略について考えている
ここでAとBはそれぞれ
XとYの関数だ。
例えば、Aのゼロは
AliceがX=0の質問を受けたときのAnswerを表し、Aの1はAliceのAnswerを表す
彼女の質問XがOneに等しいとき。
これらの4つの式は
4つのケースそれぞれで勝利条件が満たされるために
真でなければならないものだ。
例えば、XがZeroに等しく
YがZeroに等しければ、AとBの排他的論理和は
Zeroに等しくなければならない、
一方XがOneに等しくYがOneに等しい場合、
AとBの排他的論理和はOneに等しくなければならない。
これらの式がすべて真になるように
AとBの関数を選ぶ方法がないことを確認する一つの方法は、単純に全ての式の排他的論理和を取ることだ。
任意の2値とそれ自身の排他的論理和はZeroに等しいので、
左辺の排他的論理和は
Zeroに等しいことが導かれる。
なぜならAのZeroが2つ、AのOneが2つあるからだ、
BのZeroが2つ
BのOneが2つある。
それら全てのXORを取ると
最終的にZeroになるが、式の右辺の排他的論理和を取ると、
Zeroではなく1が得られる。したがって4つの式が全て真であることはあり得ず、少なくとも1つは間違っていなければならない
そしてそれは
4つのケースの少なくとも1つでAliceとBobの負けにつながる。
したがって、審判が質問を
均一に選ぶので、決定論的戦略を使って
AliceとBobが勝つ確率は
せいぜい4分の3、つまり75%だ。
AliceとBobが4分の3の確率で勝てるというのは実は非常に簡単に見て取れる。
例えばAliceとBobが両方とも常にZeroと答えるなら、
4回中3回は
正解になる。
AliceとBobは決定論的戦略を使って
75%より良い成績を
出すことはできない。
では確率的戦略についてはどうだろうか？
確率的戦略を使っても
全く助けにならないことがわかっている。それはすべての確率的戦略が
決定論的戦略をランダムに選択したものと
見ることができるからで、確率的操作が
決定論的操作のランダムな選択と
見られるのと同じで、最初のレッスンで見た通りだ。
平均は最大値より
大きくなることはないので、確率的戦略は勝つという観点から
何の優位性も
決定論的戦略に対してもたらさない。これにはAliceとBobのランダムな選択が相関している可能性も含まれる。
つまり、結論として4分の3の確率で勝つことが
AliceとBobが古典的戦略を使って達成できる最善であり、
それが決定論的であれ
確率的であれ。
この時点で自然に生じる問いは、AliceとBobが量子戦略を使ってより良い成績を出せるかどうかで、特に
ゲームをプレイする前に準備できた
もつれた量子状態を共有していた場合、それが助けになるかということだ。
答えはYesで、それができる。それがこの例のポイントであり、だからこそとても興味深いのだ。
では、entanglementを使ってAliceとBobがこのゲームでどのようにより良い成績を出せるかを正確に見てみよう。
まず必要なのは、各角度thetaに対して量子状態ベクトルChi
thetaを定義することだ。画面で確認できる。
Chi thetaはcosine thetaのket zeroと
sine thetaのket oneの和に等しい。ちなみにここでは、
角度はラジアン単位で
考えている。
例えば、thetaがpi over
fourつまり45度の場合に得られるベクトルはこれだ。
pi over fourのcosineと
sine of pi over fourはどちらも
1 over square root of twoに等しいから、
これはplus stateの別名に過ぎない。
もう一つの例として、thetaが3 times pi over eightの場合だ。
3 times pi over eightのsineを
頭の中で即座に思い出せなくても、
ここにsineとcosineの表があるから
実際に必要になるものは
この例全体を通して
この特定のベクトルに必要なものも含めて確認できる。
次に、角度alphaとbetaとして、
これらのベクトルのうち任意の2つの内積を取りたい場合、
それは簡単にできる。
これらのベクトルの成分は実数だけなので
複素共役を気にする必要はなく、
cosineの積が得られる。
にsineの積を加えたものになる。いわゆる
加法定理の一つを使えば
それを簡略化できる。
角度の差のcosine、
つまりcosine関数は
ゼロを中心に対称だから、
どちらの順に取っても実は関係ない。
こういった三角関数の公式を
暗記していなくても大丈夫だ、
自分だけじゃないから安心してほしい。覚えなくても
調べれば済む。ただ、内積の
幾何学的な解釈を考えると
実数単位ベクトル間の内積がそれらの間の角度のcosineであることが、
この式の意味を納得させてくれる。
これらのベクトルのうち任意の2つのテンソル積と
Phi plus stateの内積を計算すると、
似たような式が得られる。
ただし分母に
square root of twoが入る。
Phi plus stateがこの例の文脈で
初めて登場したのはここだ。
なぜこの特定の内積に注目するのかは
すぐに分かるが、今のところは
先ほど得たのと同じ式が
内積をsquare root of twoで割ったものとして
得られることを確認しておこう。なので以前と同様に簡略化できる。
次に、各角度thetaに対して
ユニタリ行列U thetaを定義する。
右側で見ての通りだ。
これが確かにユニタリ行列であることは
簡単に確認できる。
重要なのは、ベクトルsi thetaが
ベクトルsi theta plus pi over twoに直交しているという点だ。
これは理にかなっている。
pi over two、つまり90度だけ回転させると
直交ベクトルが得られるからだ。
U thetaにU theta daggerを掛けると
単位行列が得られる。
直感的に言えば、
この行列が演算として行うのは
si thetaをket zeroに、si theta plus pi over twoをket oneに写すことだ。
この時点で、AliceとBobの戦略を
記述するために必要なものは
全て揃った。
まず、テレポーテーションや超高密度符号の時と同様に、AliceとBobはe-bitを共有した状態から始める。
Aliceはqubit Aを持ち、
Bobはqubit Bを持つ。そして2つのqubitは合わせて
Phi plus stateにある。
Aliceの行動は次の通りだ。審判から受け取ったビットXを確認して、
Xがゼロに等しければ
AにU zeroを適用する。U zeroは単位行列なので
これは何もしないのと同じだ。
一方Xが1に等しければ、AにU pi over fourを適用する。
2つの操作のどちらかを
適用した後、標準基底測定を使って
Aを測定し、得られた結果を
審判に送る。
Bobも非常に似たことをする。彼のqubitはもちろんBと呼ばれ、
XではなくYを審判から受け取る。
しかし重要な違いは、
ユニタリ演算に異なる角度を
使う点だ。
Yがゼロに等しければU pi over eightを
適用し、Yが1に等しければu negative pi over eightを適用する。
これらの角度の選択がなぜ良い選択なのかはすぐに分かるが、
全く自明ではない。
そして、この戦略を表す
circuit図がこれだ。
今回はBobが上、Aliceが
下にいる。入ってくるe-bitがここだ。
そしてこれらがXとYの値によって
AliceとBobが適用するかもしれない
ユニタリgateだ。
この2つについては、ビットXまたはビットYによって
制御されているgateがある。
そしてここにある2つは
制御gateのように見えるが、
円が塗りつぶされていない。
これが意味するのは、
制御ビットがゼロにセットされていればgateが実行され、
制御がゼロにセットされていれば何も起きないということだ。
つまり、通常の制御gateと同じだが
制御のゼローと1の役割が
入れ替わっているだけだ。
実質的にBobは
Yがゼロに等しければここのgateを実行し、
ここのgateを実行する。
YがイコールOneの場合、同様にAliceはXがイコールZeroなら
ここのgateを、XがイコールOneなら
こっちのgateを適用する。
つまり、これがAliceとBobの戦略で、あとはそれが
どれだけうまく機能するかを確認するだけだ。
今説明した量子戦略の分析には、実際のところ
この時点で必要なものが二つだけある。まず、
ユニタリ行列UシータはここにあるようにU Thetaで
このとおりで、
もう一つはこの公式だ。
ベクトルsi thetaの定義はもう必要ない。この二つの式だけで十分だ。
考慮すべきケースが四つあって、
まずケース一から始める。XはZero、
YはZeroの場合だ。
戦略を振り返ると、このケースではAliceが自分のqubitに
U zeroを適用し、BobはU pi over eightを
自分のqubitに適用することがわかる。
AliceはBottomでBobはTopにいる
ことを覚えておいてほしい。二人が得る状態は
このようになる。
U thetaの定義に従って展開すると、
ここに見えるこの式が
得られる。
もう一方の公式が
助けてくれるので、それ以上展開する
必要はない。
四つの項それぞれにその公式を
適用すると、こうなる。
この時点でAliceとBobが両者とも測定し、結果の
分布を説明するテーブルがここにある。
確率を求めるために係数の絶対値の
二乗を取る。これは係数の
二乗と等しい。
このケースでは係数が
すべて実数だからだ。
レッスンの前の方で求めたサインとコサインの値と
いくつかの対称性を使えば、
これらの確率をここに示したように表せる。
最終列のとおりだ。
本当に重要なのは二人が勝つ確率で、
XとYが両方ZeroのケースではA
とBが等しい場合に勝つ
ことを覚えていてほしい。AとBが異なる場合は負けになる。
それらの確率を計算すると、AとBが等しい確率は
この値とこの値の和であることがわかる。
それはルートニーを足した二を
四で割った値、約85%に等しい。
AとBが等しくない確率はルートニーを引いた二を四で割った値で、
当然この量の一マイナス、
つまり先ほど計算した値になる。
このケースでは約85%の確率で
勝てるということだ。
あと三つのケースを考える必要があるが、
どれもこれとよく似ている。
XがZeroでYがOneの場合、BobはU pi over eightではなく
U negative pi over eightを適用する。
公式の値は多少変わるが、
前のケースとまったく
同じ確率になる。
XがZeroでYがOneの場合、AliceとBobはやはり
AとBが等しいときに勝つので、
勝利確率はまったく
同じだ。
三番目のケース、XがOneでYがZeroの場合も
似たような状況だ。角度は異なるが、
互いにまったく
同じ関係にあり、実際に
前のケースとまったく同じベクトルが
得られる。
確率も同じで、勝利確率も同じだ。
最後のケースは少し
異なる。予想どおり、
このケースでは勝利条件が異なるからだ。
XとYが両方Oneのとき、AliceとBobはAとBが
異なる場合に勝つ。
基本的な手順は同じだが、角度は異なり、今回はここのベクトルが
得られる。
必要な引き算を順番に行えば確認できるはずだ。
確率はついに変化し、必要な値を調べると
確率が実質的に
前とは入れ替わっていることがわかる。今度はAがBに等しくない確率が
二つのうちの大きい方で、
でもそれでいい。このケースではAliceとBobは
AとBが等しくない場合に勝つからだ。
なので今回も約85%の確率で
勝てる。
すべてのケースで同じ確率で勝てる。
つまりルートニーを足した二を四で割った値、
約85%で勝てるということで、
それが全体としての
勝利確率だ。
このゲームでは古典的な戦略が達成できる最大値を上回っており、
それがこれを面白くしている点だ。
これはどんな量子戦略においても最適な勝利確率だ。
どんなエンタングル状態を使っても
これ以上の結果は出ない。
この事実はTsirelson不等式として知られていて、
最初にそれを証明したBoris
Tsirelsonにちなんで名付けられており、私の知る限り彼は
最初にこの例を
ゲームとして説明した一人だ。今行った分析が
少し謎めいて見えるとしたら、
幾何学的に考えることも
可能で、角度の選び方に対する
より深い直感をつかむのに役立つかもしれない。
具体的には、ここに見える公式を使えば、
内積の式から簡単に導き出せる。
すでに求めた内積を使って、
異なる測定結果の確率を
別の形で表すことができる。
四つのケースについて次のようになる。まず、X、YがZero、Zeroの場合、
各測定結果の確率はこうなる。
様々な測定結果の確率については、
この公式を使って結論を出すために
先ほど行った分析を振り返るか見直す必要がある。
こちらでは、以前と同様に描かれた
異なる状態ベクトルが見える。カラーコードは
blueが
結果Zeroに対応し、redが
結果Oneに対応する。
blueのベクトル同士の角度と
redのベクトル同士の角度は
比較的小さい。
どちらの場合もpi over eightなので、コサインは比較的大きく、
それは二つの結果が
等しくなる確率が比較的大きいことを意味する。
X、YがZero、Oneの場合も似た状況で、
同じ色のベクトル同士の角度が小さいため、
等しい結果が出る確率も
また比較的大きい。
三番目のケースも似ていて、四番目のケース、
X、YがOne、Oneのときは面白いことが起きる。
今回は、単純に
これらのベクトルがどう選ばれたかによって、
同じ色のベクトル同士の角度が
比較的大きいことがわかる。具体的には両方のケースで
角度はpi over eightの三倍だ。
つまり測定結果が等しくなる確率は比較的小さい。
しかしこれはAliceとBobが
答えが異なる場合に勝つ
唯一のケースなので、望ましい結果だ。
改めて、ベクトルを確認しよう。X、YがZero、Zeroの場合、
X、YがZero、Oneの場合、
X、YがOne、Zeroの場合、
そしてX、YがOne、Oneの場合だ。
この幾何学的な図は、
この戦略がどのように機能するかについて
直感を養うのに役立つだろう。
また、様々な角度がなぜこのような形で選ばれたかについてもだ。
レッスンの締めくくりとして、
CHSHゲームについて
簡単にいくつかの補足をしたい。
まず、すでに述べたように、この例は必ずしも
ゲームとして説明されるわけではない。
例えば物理学のコミュニティでは、
この例は単純に実験として
説明される方が一般的で、
AliceとBobはプレイヤーではなく
検出器として捉えられる。
エンタングルメントが古典的な記述とは
相容れない統計的結果をもたらすという、
このような実験の基本的な考え方、
より一般的には局所隠れ変数と呼ばれる
理論に基づいたいかなる理論とも相容れないという考え方は、
Bell状態の名の由来でもあるJohn Bellによるものだ。
そのため、この種の実験を
Bell testと呼ぶことが多い。
Bellの定理と呼ばれることもある。様々な形で定式化できるが、基本的には量子力学が
いわゆる局所隠れ変数理論と
相容れないと述べるものだ。
CHSHゲームまたは不等式は、Bell testの
非常にきれいでわかりやすい例だ。
この例をBellの定理の
証明または実証として捉えることもできる。
二番目の補足は、CHSHゲームが量子情報の理論を
実験的に検証する一つの方法を
提供してくれるということだ。CHSHゲームを実装した実験を実際にセットアップできる。
先ほど説明したエンタングルメントに基づいた
戦略を含めてだ。そしてそれがうまくいくか
確認できる。実際うまくいく。
これにより、エンタングルメントが実在することへの
高い確信が得られる。また、エンタングルメントを説明しようとする
やや漠然とした、または詩的な試みとは異なり、
CHSHゲームまたは実験は
エンタングルメントを観察するための
具体的な
テスト可能な方法を提供してくれる。
それが重要に聞こえるとしたら、
実際に重要だからだ。2022年のノーベル物理学賞は
まさにこれを称えるものだ。
賞はAlain Aspect、CHSHのCにあたるJohn Clauser、
そしてAnton Zeilingerに
授与された。
エンタングルした光子を使った実験でBell不等式の
違反を実証した。言い換えれば、
私が説明したような量子戦略が
実際に機能し、古典的な戦略を上回ることを示したのだ。
さらに詳しく知りたい方は、Qiskit YouTubeチャンネルで
私の同僚Olivia Lanesが
Bells Theoremについて解説している動画を
ぜひチェックしてほしい。
最後に、非局所ゲームという話題は全体として
本当に魅力的で、
活発な研究分野だ。
物理学、計算機科学、純粋数学を
結びつけるもので、まだ多くの
興味深い問いが
非局所ゲームについて
今日まで未解決のまま残っている。
これでレッスン四の終わり、そして量子情報の基礎
シリーズのユニット一の
終わりでもある。
最初のレッスンでは孤立した単一システムに対して
量子情報がどのように機能するかを説明し、
二番目のレッスンでは量子情報が
複数のシステムに対してどのように機能するかを説明した。
これは単一システムの場合から
かなり自然に生まれてくるものだ。
三番目のレッスンでは量子circuit計算モデルを紹介し、
四番目のレッスンではエンタングルメントを使って
できる三つの重要な例を見た。
エンタングルメントで
できることを示す例だ。
その過程で、テンソル積や内積を含む
非常に重要な数学的概念をいくつか見て、
量子情報の
基本的な制約についても
観察した。
シリーズの次のユニットにもぜひ参加してほしい。
量子アルゴリズムについてで、量子情報が
どのような計算上の優位性をもたらすかという問いに
焦点を当てていく。
ではまた。